let me remind you that the david pakman
show
is mostly funded by people who sign up
at joinpakman.com everyone is welcome
regardless of
age regardless of national origin you
can sign up from anywhere in the world
and people regularly do
and it is the primary funding source for
our program so consider yourselves
invited you will get the
award-winning awards we give out but
still award-winning bonus show every
single day
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
at joinpackman.com let's see what's on
the minds
of some of our viewers and listeners we
are going to go to the phone lines at
617-830-4750
with our caller from the 214 area code
caller from 214 what's your name
and where are you calling from
hello dave hang on one second i'm trying
to get you back where
okay you there i'm here
hey this is dave calling from dallas
texas and uh
thank you for taking my call yeah uh so
whenever
people get on unemployment they
typically don't get their full paycheck
i think they get something like 60 or 70
percent
so when i heard that first heard that
they were going to be giving an extra
600
to people on unemployment i assume they
were going to give people the difference
between you know their paycheck and you
know what they would have gotten
unemployment up to a maximum of 600
right so i was pretty shocked when i
heard they were going to give everybody
an extra 600 and i think right now
they're looking at maybe even extending
that
so i think a better use of that money
would be to of course give unemployed
people
their the equivalent of their full
paycheck but then
use the rest of that money to maybe help
small business owners
and the self-employed who in many cases
have seen their income drop dramatically
and in some cases had it taken away
completely because they were forced to
shut down
entirely so i'm just wondering if you
think that's the best use
well so remember dave that the it turns
out that
there was money left over in the ppp
fund as far as i most recently saw so
there was actually you know your your
idea of taking some money out of
unemployment and giving it to small
businesses
small businesses didn't even scoop up
the money that was available so
it's unclear to me that that's really
the solution now what it sounds like
your concern is and i understand the
concern it's should anybody be making
more on unemployment than by working
that seems to be the fundamental concern
you have right
no actually it's not my fundamental
concern is that with the ppp program
that's that's really helping the
employees as well
only 75 percent of a ppp loan has to be
used
to pay your employees that's correct the
business owners only get
25 percent so the business owner the
only help that the government is often
offering business owners
is debt in the form of low interest sba
loans and maybe helping you with 25
on your rent for your utilities yeah i
mean a lot a lot of that is forgivable
remember so it's not it's not alone in
practice but i think i'm now better
understanding
what you're saying which is the ppp
would allow you to keep your employees
on and pay them but it doesn't generate
demand necessarily for what you're
selling and your business revenue may be
in the tank what if the some of the
money could be used for that
instead yeah but you know
i guess what i'm talking about too is
things like you know the guy who used to
cut my hair
and i said you used to cut my hair
because i'm not going to get my hair
cutting yeah right
he's his business has gone off
dramatically i know a lady who's
uh who has a event planning business
she has literally no business now right
you know she her business is
gone my wife for example owns a pet
sitting company
pet sitters depend on people traveling
or having to go to a job every day and
needing their dog taken out in the
middle of the day
her business is down 70 percent right
you know so now david did you did you
know that
i know your concern is sole proprietors
here i don't know if you knew
but the unemployment benefits were
expanded to include
sole proprietors and people who work for
themselves who normally
would not qualify for unemployment and i
think that that's important as well i
don't know if you knew that
yeah i did not know that yeah yeah yeah
so i actually called my representatives
and asked them what they were doing to
help people like my wife
yeah and i've been just told basically
about the ppp loan
and i point out to them well that's
really not for the the employer that's
really for the employee more mostly
right no i know i know like for example
um i know social media consultants who
just work for themselves who have gone
on unemployment and they would not
normally be able to
uh but but they they were i mean listen
the details
are are in some cases not perfect but
overall the situation is a mess i don't
think that the government has done
nearly enough when you compare us to
other countries but it seems like you
know on the details we could certainly
talk about it all day
yeah well let me ask you one more thing
do you think that that
actually that this whole 600 extra
dollars
actually kind of feeds into the
conservative narrative that democrats or
socialists who want to pay people not to
work that's another thing about it i
will say
well it's the trump administration who
did it and it's trump who said that he
was very much in favor of it so
i guess is trump the socialist is what i
would say to them
i agree with you i'm just saying that
that's what that's why conservatives are
going to spend it they're not going to
say trump's association
well then i'd say i tell him if you
don't like it vote trump out because
trump's the guy who did it
i i agree with that that's actually a
that's a good comeback on that
and uh before i let you go can i just
make one other quick comment yeah
something i've been hearing you and a
lot of other people saying sure i keep
hearing people say that biden has to win
in the landslide
that this has to be a decisive victory
you know in my lifetime i don't think
i've ever heard
republicans say they have to win in a
landslide in fact i don't think they
think they have to win
they just think they have to convince us
that they won by at least one vote
right i think it's great to say we have
to win the landslide maybe you guys
should also throw in the caveat at the
end of the day
just like the republicans all we have to
do is win even if it's only by one vote
i agree with you we only have to win by
one vote it would be better to prevent
trump
from doing more of his shenanigans to
win by more than one vote but you're
completely right you only need to win by
one
all right dave from dallas thank you for
the call i appreciate it
a lot of a lot of important issues there